make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
light of what's going on with
wandavision a lot of people over at pop
culture explained have asked me to make
a video explaining sword uh now one of
the things that i'm trying to do here is
make sure there is a clear distinction
between
pop culture explained and comics
explained comics explain is of course
a comic book channel and so a lot of the
in-depth explanations regarding comic
book characters teams things like that
will stay on this channel
uh pop culture explained with regards to
those explanations will get more of a
stripped down version
right so i do have a full on mephisto
explained video here on this channel
you'll find a link to it down in the
description
uh but i'll probably create more of like
a stripped-down explanation for pop
culture explain that's like 10 minutes
long right and it's more or less just
the essential facts
but um but with regards to sword one
thing to understand here is sword is not
an overly complex concept in marvel
comics meaning it does not appear very
often sword i think has something like a
hundred appearances of marvel and that's
it it's like 106. if i want to start
splitting hairs and being more detailed
uh but it's got 106 appearances in
marvel comics and they don't really show
up that often and the reason why is
because there really
isn't a huge need for them so you have
sword as it originally appeared and then
it just wasn't relevant again until you
got to the alpha flight space program
which was led by carol danvers but
uh but the original sword was introduced
by joss whedon and john cassaday and
first appeared in astonishing x-men
issue number one and this all went into
something called break world which was
basically a guy by the name of ord
and the idea was that at some future
point in time ort had come to realize
that a mutant would lead to the
destruction of his world and so in order
to keep that from happening he intended
to come to earth and basically
obliterate the world before
so he didn't have to worry about it at
all what ended up happening here is that
we were introduced to abigail brand
by way of nick fury now the way that
sword was initially introduced to us
is that if shield monitors threats on
earth from various teams right advanced
idea mechanics hydra factor three
different things like that
then the purpose of sword was to monitor
space and that's why sword's name
originally stood for the sentient world
observation and response department they
would basically monitor all these
different worlds out there that existed
across the universe and the galaxy and
if any of them
posed a credible threat to earth then
sword would intervene and sword's reach
was pretty
far right they would actually have spies
and like a lot of the major empires the
shia
empire the kree empire the scroll empire
they had spies all over the place and
they would basically feed information
back to sword's leader
a woman by the name of abigail brandt
and abigail brand was a mutant she had
the ability to create kind of like a
plasma flame on her hands but the
biggest benefit of abigail brand
as her tongue was shaped in such a way
to where she could basically understand
and translate any alien language now
it's not
any language ever in general right
that's a power that belongs to cipher
right he understands every language in
existence abigail brand was only able to
understand
alien language right so beings that do
not originate on earth but that's why
she was ultimately chosen to lead the
program
because what better person to have in
the position of somebody who's going to
be monitoring extraterrestrial worlds
than a person who can translate
extraterrestrial languages
and so because of that what ended up
happening in the original break world
story
is that ultimately in order to avoid a
interstellar conflict between earth and
break world itself which really wouldn't
be much of a conflict right because
earth doesn't really have much in the
way of like orbital defenses uh you
ended up having abigail bran broke her
piece and so far she allowed ord
to basically create a quote unquote cure
to the uh to the mutant gene and that's
why the first story arc of astonishing
x-men is called the cure we've also got
a link to that down in the description
and you're welcome to watch that video
as well if you want to get the the
nitty-gritty behind it now ultimately
the
this story had a couple big points the
first thing was that it did introduce
sword the second thing is it actually
resurrected uh colossus it brought
colossus back in the sense that where he
was believed to have been killed in 1997
by virtue of the legacy virus
essentially sacrificing his life to
create a cure then in fact his body was
taken by ord and it just been
experimented on all this time and it was
a really cool moment when he came back
it was a really really great moment we
won't deviate too far you can check out
the video if you want to know about that
but in the aftermath of this sword
basically became a background concept
right they would appear here and there
and abigail brand would offer some
assistance to the x-men whenever they
needed it right if there was some kind
of a
scroll event or the x-men had to go into
space or you would see her appear in
different stories involving the avengers
or something like that but for the most
part you didn't really see her
really didn't see sword becoming
relevant until you got to like secret
invasion
and then basically a scroll managed to
blow up the peak which was the name of
the space station that sword was based
off of
and that was it right you saw a couple
things here and there but it was just
small tiny little moments they really
are not
a very in-depth or complex team but from
there
that's when you go into the alpha flight
program or the alpha flight space
program
in the aftermath of secret wars so in
the aftermath of what was going on with
regards to
seeker wars right the destruction of the
multiverse and its recreation
and all that kind of stuff marvel wanted
to rework a couple different things the
first thing was that sword
was it was exactly what we said it was
right just a thing that existed and
while sword had been a subsect
of shield albeit allowed to operate with
a measure of autonomy meaning it did not
directly answer to shield it was just
kind of considered to be arcade right it
never really served any useful purpose
of marvel comics outside of the
occasional
event that may have required abigail
brand to show up or something like that
but it was a team you never really heard
of and so marvel wanted to kind of
reshuffle things so coming in the
aftermath of kelly sue deconyx landmark
run on captain marvel which if you've
never read it i
highly suggest you do it's probably the
single greatest captain marvel run
that's ever been written with carol
danvers
but in the aftermath of the popularity
of that coupled with the fact that alpha
flight was basically a canadian
superhero team that by all standards of
measurement
just sucked uh marvel ended up
restructuring the entire concept right
and so sword as we knew it was
effectively made defunct
and that in turn it was replaced with
the alpha flight space program now for
all intents and purposes
they were basically the same thing just
a different name except the alpha flight
program was led by carol danvers
and sword was led by abigail brandt
right that was the only real difference
between these things
uh alpha flight seemed to have more of a
hands-on approach uh but again we didn't
really see a whole lot of them i mean
you saw a lot in the beginning of carol
danvers run but a lot of that with with
you know the all-new captain marvel who
was largely just based with like carol
danvers focusing on the stress
of running you know the alpha flight
space program and how underfunded it was
and all that kind of stuff it wasn't
really
great in terms of landmark storytelling
with regards to like this alien
invasion's coming that alien invasion is
coming different things like that that
didn't really take place until the
events of secret empire
when uh the red skull got his hands on a
sentient cosmic cube and then had it
rewrite all of captain america's history
right to change steve rogers history
from being the world war ii hero that we
know to being a guy who was an agent of
hydra
when that took place one of the things
that that steve rogers had done
is he had basically stolen a handful of
eggs that basically would produce queens
belonging to the chitauri army and what
this did is it led to the tatari force
constantly launching an attack against
earth in order to keep the alpha flight
space program preoccupied which would
allow steve rogers to essentially create
a hold over
the united states and then eventually
earth without having to worry about
these super strong
characters like hyperion and those guys
getting involved uh he essentially
tricked congress into creating a force
field around the earth
that would keep the earth protected and
would help bolster the defenses of the
alpha flight space program and so when
that shield was erected the ability for
it to be taken down was nullified right
captain america was like the only one
who could do it and this basically
stranded
the uh alpha flight space program
members between the constantly
you know just this constant bombardment
of chitari forces and like the force
field and they were basically trying to
keep you know trying to fight off these
atari forces under the belief
that the sheer number of these guys who
were constantly just throwing themselves
against the shield would eventually lead
to its collapse
all the while being totally unaware of
what steve rogers was doing on earth
right and so uh that was really the big
point of them and you actually ended up
seeing the space station of the alpha
flight program destroyed this basically
led to
uh the members of the alpha flight space
program being stuck on earth for a
little while and then ultimately carol
danvers stepped down uh when you ended
up getting into the story that came with
captain marvel volume 10 and marvel
basically reworking the character of
carol danvers to essentially be a
copy of her version in the marvel
cinematic universe where instead of her
getting her powers from
essentially the original captain marvel
uh marvel of the cree that instead she
was park cree right they just kind of
reworked all that but when that
knowledge became public uh she
ultimately ended up stepping down
abigail brand took her place and then
abigail brandquit and then henry peter
gyrik the original
well really just one of the original old
school x-men villains
ended up becoming the new leader of it
all but there's not a whole lot going
when it comes to sword now if we want to
expand this conversation offer a little
more meat and potatoes to this we can
really invoke what's going on in wand
division
right with the sentient weapon
observation and response division is
what it's called the issue
with this is we don't really know
anything about it sword as we know it in
the marvel cinematic universe this is
our first real indication of its
existence right the only thing we had
before this
was a post-credits scene where you had
nick fury just basically getting up on a
space station and that was it
right that's all that we had we don't
really know the full brunt of what sword
does in the mcu outside of its namesake
which seems to be monitoring sentient
weapons and the actions of wanda
maximoff in the marvel cinematic
universe with regards to the one
division show has drawn their attention
now the extent of this how it's all
going on at the time that we're
recording this video we don't really
know right but we're like three days
away from episode four and i'm sure
that'll be a flashback to kind of show
us how sword got involved what sword
does all that kind of good stuff
explaining all those
those bits and pieces a lot of the
things we can kind of assemble on our
own right we know that like monica rambo
is basically an agent of sword that
seems to have been sent there herb is
probably a sword member as well
um and and agatha hartness is probably
working on behalf of sword and that they
were all sent
in but much like with monica as soon as
they entered this force field their
minds were basically wiped and they
became the characters that were created
for them by
wanda maximoff which really explains why
it is that monica seemed to
seem to understand things when she made
that comment about quicksilver and
ultron that she seemed to be kind of
confused right like remembering it as
she was saying it uh that's probably the
reason why she was kind of regaining her
memories at that point in time
the question is why why right like why
that happened to take place most likely
because when wanda was talking about her
brother she was distracted and that led
to her control over
monica sort of releasing for him for a
brief moment much in the same way it did
with dottie
when uh when the radio started going off
and then dottie returned back to her
normal self for a brief moment but
whatever the case happens to be
uh we don't really know a whole lot
about what's going on with sword in the
marvel cinematic universe we will as
time goes on and i guarantee we'll have
an exceedingly solid understanding of
what sword is about by the time we enter
one division the real question to ask
here is what sword what role sword is
going to play
in the future of the mcu for the most
part sword was most likely created in
the aftermath of the original avengers
film if not the original avengers film
then certainly thanos arriving on earth
uh we know that it came out a result out
of a result of that
and seeing people like thanos being as
powerful as he is being a sentient
weapon although it could be that it was
just created as a result of wanda doing
whatever she's been doing because we
don't know how long she's been doing it
for
right we don't know how long wanda has
been manipulating everything that's been
going on
if one division picks up six months
after this started three years
five years like we don't really know
because all we have are the people
inside this bubble
and we know that like monica is at some
point older but you know
it's kind of hard to gauge how old she
is right because we don't really have a
frame of reference we have her as a
little kid and then we have her now
right we don't really know
you know what's going on if i had to
guess she's in her late 20s early 30s
right and and we kind of go from there
but nonetheless you know it's uh it's
it's one of these things where
um you know the future of the mc will
give us a lot of answers in terms of
what we're looking for but with regards
to
the comic book version of sword there's
not a lot doing there and you would
think there would be
because the they originally appeared
something like 16 years ago and you
would think that over the course of the
last 16 years
marvel would have done a lot with them
but with the exception of the peak being
destroyed
in secret uh secret invasion and a few
other things that happened with the with
the the the group itself
there wasn't really a whole lot
happening there they've just never
really been been as significant as a
group like shield granite shield's been
around since the 60s of marvel comics
right so it's been around for a long
long time but
uh but yeah i mean there's not a whole
lot going there so with that being said
guys if you guys are interested in
checking out pop culture explained all
of our theories on wanda vision and
things like that make sure you guys
check the
the end screens here and the video and
uh we're gonna bring this to an end if
you guys are new here to comments
explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
what does that mean
[Music]
anymore
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
foreign